hey everyone it's Mike from
immortalflows and welcome back to my
channel I'm glad you could join me for
today's video which is going to be an
interesting topic it sort of revolves
around you know sticking to your trading
plan
um is there luck in trading and maybe a
few other uh topics as as uh as they
sort of come up in the discussion but
before I jump in you know if you've been
enjoying these videos be sure to
subscribe to the channel click the
notification Bell so you don't miss any
new video that I post and again if you
find today's video helpful and be sure
to hit the like button and leave a
comment uh sharing you know your
thoughts on the video and whether you
know there's a topic you want me to
cover in another video so today
um you know it was kind of interesting
in this is a trade couple of Trades I
took here in the ym today and you know
uh sort of a topic that I think you know
comes up sometimes in in trading is is
there luck involved and you know there's
I don't say there's luck involved but
there's some because there's some degree
of Randomness and uncontrollable factors
in the market that we just have no uh
control over now there's going to be
times where you're just lucky or unlucky
you know my kids play uh you know some
competitive soccer leagues and you know
sometimes there's these goals that are
scored and it just makes no sense and
it's just unlucky right and in trading
sometimes you find yourself in those
situations now this was a trade that I
took in the mini thought I got short
here at Market was starting to come up
here to 78 then started to come off a
bit I got short here at 46 I had 20 tick
stop
uh more or less up here at uh
40 my stops at 66 right so I'm short at
46 and then the market starts trading
down and starts coming up and it's not
me out right up here at 66. two lots
traded up there okay I can see that on
the footprint too I was one of those
contracts somebody bought one my stop
got triggered now I'm not gonna sit here
say oh you know they're a gun
information somebody cares about a
stupid one lot uh order in the market
it's just unlucky right that's one of
those unlucky situations where it just
literally goes stops you out right to
the tick and you know it's just it's
just one of those things where you just
like you know as a Trader like really it
came up there one lot traded the other
one lot is my stop getting triggered one
out of that two then the market starts
coming down now this is where
you know understanding yourself as a
Trader right is is going to be a big
help now I know right Revenge trading is
bad right sometimes we sort of get
stopped out on something like oh you
know what I'm right you know we always
have this Fascination that it's you
against the market like
um you know it's like uh the market
screwed me I'm gonna show this Market I
want to get uh you know I'm gonna start
trading again and but I know that you
know based off of my analysis
um that you know I felt this Market
should continue to go down I got short
again I put in in order to get short at
46 it was a stop I got filled at 45. so
originally I was short at 46 Market
traded back up right to my stop level
now I'm not saying don't get me wrong
I'm not insinuating nothing to that
effect that oh you know they were
gunning for myself it's just unlucky
that it turned you know if it got within
one tick right here at 65 and then
turned around that would have been fine
I wouldn't be making this video but it
you know there's those instant instances
where
it just sort of goes right up to your
your stop it trades there and then the
market reverses
and again knowing yourself as a Trader
and knowing you know having confidence
in what you're doing your analysis
is going to tell you hey you know what I
was unlucky here I got stopped out here
at you know at the high of this bar
but I still feel bearish on this Market
I got short again here again at 45 this
was you know 46 was my original level
and you know again I just dropped in to
sell stop get short I guess I got short
here at 45.
Market started going down got down to
38th I'm feeling hey great you know then
it pops back up to 50. again so it's
like five ticks against me I'm not
worried about that
and again I'm looking for a move down to
you know below this yellow line which is
the opening price I'm looking for a move
uh much lower
than that and it started coming in and
then I started seeing the bearish order
flow right this bar is what I was
looking for to come in here not you know
this green candle where it sort of pops
up and comes back down I was looking for
this Supply to come into the market
and then for the market to drop below
this 23 level which was the opening
price
um you know eventually I covered down
here at 16.
so you know I lost the 20 ticks on that
one pop up there okay you know you have
to
um you know you have you got stops in
there for a reason right but sometimes
you just get unlucky and you get stopped
out literally
to the tick but you have to accept that
you know there's risks involved right
don't
don't start thinking that I don't need
to stop right you do need to stop yeah
it's unlucky that I got stopped out at
45 but
we're trading back down I'm sorry
stopped out at 66 but if we're trading
back down immediately at 45 I'm still
you know nothing has really changed for
me in the sense of yeah you got this one
green candle okay but you know
even though we trade back up there and
we're trading back down I'm still
looking at sort of the slightly bigger
picture than this my new one bar here
that I should still want to be bearish
okay then finally the bearish order flow
finally showed up in here
um sort of you know to make that move to
where I was expecting the market so you
know I took a loss on the on trade 26
but then you know on the next trade came
right back I believed in my you know I
have sound
uh analysis that yeah I'm still looking
for this move to happen
and it happened so that that's in my
opinion that's not Revenge trading right
Revenge trading is where you you get
frustrated
and then you start jumping in on trades
that make no sense right as long as you
have some sort of sound analysis that's
going into how you're trading then you
know you're going to want to take those
trades
but again you know if case you're sort
of wondering why I got short I think I'm
getting short here at this 46-ish area
well you know I didn't you know again
today is Thursday tomorrow's not in
front of payrolls I I'm expecting came
in here sort of expecting kind of a
quiet session and you know I just sort
of want to catch some of these these
moves I just didn't see much strength in
this move up here
um you know obviously this green candle
I was looking for more to come out of it
um then I see the aggressive selling
coming in here a nice solid negative
Delta coming in another
nice I'll say nice negative Delta this
is only -14 but I just don't see that
strong aggressive buying in the max
Deltas coming in here
um then obviously in this bar by the
time I get
short you know the Delta was still
around minus 40 as well so I just saw it
building up
um there but again you can see the max
Deltas are kind of small
coming in here so again yeah I just felt
there really wasn't much to this move up
I thought that if we could catch a break
we could break down towards the 23 and
just sort of rotate around there which
we did here but again this move from
about 905 to about 9 13. this move right
in here I was looking for it to take
place right here not get this green
candle up and this big red candle down
but again I felt confident enough in my
analysis I just felt that that stop out
was just unlucky right because if I got
stopped out here at okay I got short of
46 Market trades up here I get stopped
out at 45 and we're trading you know I'm
sorry stop taught us that's what I hate
about ninjatrader my stop I got stopped
out here it says 66 but it's on the
bottom this 45 is where I got short like
I stopped out at 66 if we're still
trading around you know 60 65 even
higher or somewhere you know above 55 I
wouldn't be thinking of getting short
immediately but I I just know
um that sometimes you just get that
little burst up and then it just comes
right back immediately I probably want
to still be short based off my analysis
and it comes down because you know again
sort of talking about the randomness of
trading right sometimes there's just
uncontrollable factors right I don't
know that as soon as I get short
a big buyer stepped into the market you
know that had
some volume they needed to buy to help
push this market up but once that order
is done
okay let's see how the market reacts to
it it came right back down
that's why I got short again
and the second time worked first time
yeah I got stopped out but you got to
take those losses you still got to have
a stop right if I if I didn't have a
stop right I tell you what would happen
right I'd be short at 46.
it trades up to 66 which would be my
stop and the next thing I know would be
trading 80 right and I'd be instead of a
20 tick loss I'm you know looking at
you know a 30 40 tick loss that's how it
goes if you don't have a stop and stop
is too technically uh
let's say Protect you but you know it's
defining your risk
then
again short at 45 in here but my stop
again is still going to be about here at
65. if it comes back up to 65 fine I
take the stop I'd have two losses in a
row so be it Okay so
again is there luck in trading no not
really but there's times where you're
unlucky okay and getting stopped out
right to your tick in my opinion is
unlucky you know if maybe if I had a one
take better entry here at 47 I wouldn't
have been stopped out at 66 because my
stop would be at 67.
and it is what it is all right but you
still I hate that saying it is what it
is but that's the truth it is what it is
and the market made that move back down
to you know where I was looking to
for it to go Okay so
anyway you know it's part of trading the
Journey of a Trader is
getting confident enough in your
analysis and understanding that you know
what I got stopped out but is my
analysis wrong why did I get stopped out
all right again if I got stopped out
here at 66 and then we're Trading still
hanging around 65 for the next couple of
minutes I wouldn't be thinking of
getting short again
right but the fact that it came right
back down immediately
um I was confident enough in my analysis
that maybe this buying that took place
here was very short-lived and you know I
could I could get short again and look
for that move which happened it's just
unfortunate that these two bars happen
but that's the market sometimes so
anyway guys I hope you guys enjoyed this
video I hope you get something out of it
um you know if you haven't already be
sure to subscribe to the channel so
thanks everyone I'll catch you guys on
the next video bye bye